way leblanc's not gonna overpower
anybody but he certainly has been able
to spot his fastball in the brief time
we've seen him in st louis
solano kind of punches one into right
field and donovan solano's got the first
hit of the day for the giants solano at
first
yostremski got underneath that one
kinda into no man's land carlson coming
in hard if he can't catch it now he'll
pop up and throw to second his throw is
offline
and the giants get a big break there
it'll be a hit for yostremski but then
carlson
who i think was sure that he had a
chance to force out solano couldn't do
it
that is high ball
four pitch number 21 already here in the
first inning
got him on the outside corner
and the first strikeout
for wayne leblanc and it's a big one
[Applause]
18 home runs this year
lifted in the air out to left and wade
leblanc will get out of this jam
yeah dna cueto it's always fun he's
great in day games brings the energy and
i love to watch this guy work
carlson went after that very high
fastball right into the defense ruff got
back found the bag
cueto strikes out paul goldsmith with a
great change up
3-2 arnado pops it up
bright sunshine up above daryn ruff in
front of the coach's box for out number
three nice start for cueto giants and
the cardinals for the final time in 2021
in the regular season sunday afternoon
baseball from busch stadium no score
3-2 pitch
up the middle
and position there is the young the
shortstop to make the play and a hard
hit ball
3-2 pitch
popped up to the right side
[Applause]
carpenter calling for it has it
goldie is there in foul territory with
his back to the infield
and now it's the second time through the
lineup for wade leblanc slater solano
yostrimsky here in the top of the third
got him comes back to strike him out
and the second strikeout for wayne
leblanc
here's the 1-1 pitch
and a fly ball into left
o'neal backing up to make the catch
two-way
one-two on the ground two goldschmidt
takes it himself
all of a sudden you look up
that's eight in a row set down by wade
leblanc
last of the third and the bottom third
of the order for the cardinals seven
eight nine hitters against johnny cueto
a nothing nothing game paul deyoung has
started to heat up
and use that part of the field how about
the seats
way out of here de young is red-hot
lucky number 13 on the year
one-nothing
st louis
you start spreading the ball around the
yard right you're hitting singles the
other way driving the ball out of the
park the other way gets you locked in
and ready for a hang and change up that
he pulls into the seats in left field
balance perfect swing there by paul
deyoung and you said it he's heating up
he's on fire
next down recorded by cueto will give
him 2 000 innings in major league
baseball and that is quite an
accomplishment
okay try that
vader skies one to center field
in the ballpark
and with that kind of the perfect at-bat
for johnny to hit his milestone now
exactly
2 000 innings pitched in his brilliant
big league career congratulations to
darren ruff who drew a walk in the midst
of that rally will come up for the
second time today
2-2
ruff drives one deep left field and it
is gone and all the way up into big back
land
guess who called it
darren ruff ties the game one to one
his tenth of the year
107 miles an hour off the bat boom
look at the barrel so you see how the
barrel's coming through kind of the
under and the cutter goes right into the
right-handed
like under swing when we were talking
with johnny looking at the are they are
they warming up high are they warming up
low and ruff will destroy left-handed
sliders with that bat path
it's sharply off the glove of goldie to
carpenter to leblanc and the out somehow
he stays on the bag
three
to four
to one
and an out
giants one cardinals one bottom of the
fourth inning goldschmidt base hit and
the hitting straight continues
one for two today
a couple of solo home runs in this one
yada yada swings at the first pitch on
the ground to crawford
who will throw out molina that is out
number three sequito works around that
lead off single we go to the fifth
bottom of the fifth
cardinals coming to the plate with the
score tied at one
plato got the call on the outside
carpenter could not believe it strikeout
number five for cueto
young on the ground to short
crawford
throws him out
leblanc
to solano
vader went into second with the slide
the throw went to first and johnny cueto
gets through the fifth ryan helsley last
six and two thirds opponents of hitch is
167 against him comes into a tough spot
runners at first and third nobody out
the two-two swing at a miss struck him
out 99 from ryan helsley chase to pitch
up couldn't catch up and a big first out
the one pitch hell's lead
flores
shallow center solano the runner at
third the catch is made by bader
and the throw cut off the runners don't
advance in that is out number two
that's what they're gonna do
intentionally walk crawford you did have
a base open it was second now they're
loaded up
the one-two
he struck him out what a job
hellsly
first and third nobody out and nobody
scores
he keeps it tied
1-1 another former cardinal in for the
giants john brebia who was an extremely
popular member of the cardinals the last
few years
and carpenter hits it down the right
field line
one hop over the wall and a ground rule
lead off double here in the home half of
the seventh
and the young lifts a fly ball
into right
yastrimsky will make the catch rondon
will tag the throw into third is offline
and a head first slide and the go ahead
run at third with just one down
harrison bader
at a 10 pitch at bat fly to deep center
back in the third walked in the fifth
check swing and this will bring in the
run vader to first save it first
hustling down the line and a 2-1
st louis lead
excuse me
but thank you
we just talked about it dan shorten up
put it in play make something happen
with two strikes and that's exactly what
harrison bader is able to do on this one
just gets the bat on the baseball
and beats premier to the bag
30.2 feet per second getting down the
line
an excuse me swing a smile
and a 2-1 cardinal lead
giovanni gallegos in a 2-1 ball game
the 1-2 pitch
check swing got him
they ring him up
[Music]
the 2-2
check swing
goodbye
the 2-2
got him
giovanni gallegos three strikeouts here
in the top of the eighth and none better
than this guy right here 23
consecutive saves to begin his career
and the first pitch is a fair ball oh
what a play here by goldschmidt
one pitch one out
[Applause]
3-2
ball four alex dickerson gets the tying
run on base
reyes
in the dirt ball four duggar draws the
walk back to back walks for the giants
now the tying run
is in scoring position the go-ahead run
with great speed is at first
oh one pitch
and a fly ball lifted out to right going
back carlson
he's got it
and the runner from second did not tag
0-2 pitch
fly ball into center
bader
has it the cardinals take two of three
they win it
2-1
and that's 24 straight saves to begin
the career of alex reyes without a blown
save a historic save here at bush